ich habe mitgemacht bei deutschland
spricht weil ich es spannend sind
mitmenschen zu diskutieren die ich im
realen leben niemals sprechen würde man
über denkt oder festigt seine meinung
ich finde es besonders wichtig dass wir
noch mehr und leben wo jeder seine
meinung frei äußern können und uns
irgendwelche konsequenzen und ich finde
dass in unserer gesellschaft viel zu
viel übereinander ich mir genug
miteinander gesprochen wird davon lebt
unsere demokratie vom austausch und vom
disco zweiten mal hat die faz bei der
leseraktion in deutschland spricht
teilgenommen diesmal haben wir die ganz
spontan gestartet wegen kommune wegen
der ausnahmesituation wir wollten wissen
was die leser umtreibt 9000 teilnehmer
haben sich angemeldet
am 10 bei haben dann 1000 gespräche
stattgefunden
dieses mal bin ich bin aber der meinung
dass alle doch ihr bestes gegeben haben
wahrscheinlich vergleich zur letzten
runde wird man da schon spricht haben
die müssen mal die teilnehmer stärker
polarisiert geantwortet zusammensetzung
mann frau war relativ ähnlich wir haben
80 prozent männer gehabt die geantwortet
haben und der altersdurchschnitt war
etwas älter
mit 53 jahren die paare haben sich
zusammengefunden aufgrund der antworten
die sie bei der teilnahme bei der
anmeldung gegeben haben zu 7
jaja kontroversen fragen darunter haben
wir beispielsweise gefragt wie finden
sie die krisenstrategie der
bundesregierung was halten sie von der
masken pflicht sollte es gleiche kontakt
beschränkungen für alle
bevölkerungsgruppen egal ob jung oder
alt geben
[Musik]
von den 1000 sprechen haben wir einige
ausgewählt die wir als beobachter und
zuhörer begleitet haben
wir wollten aber auch wissen wie sich
jemand fühlt der mit diskutiert und
genau das hat mein kollege martin
benninghoff gemacht hallo hallo ich
hatte ja ein gespräch mit einem mit
einem jungen mann dessen familie busch
von rumänien stammt und der körper der
bewertung wird dieses krisen management
in der korona pandemie in deutschland
läuft auch immer diesen internationalen
vergleich hat dadurch dass sich als
umgehen kommen und auch den
osteuropäischen raum kenne ist hier
unglaublich viel informiert worden
im gegensatz zu er war es eher
beschränkt ja das war für mich natürlich
dann auch ein punkt klar das muss ich
sofort verstehen das ist eine ganz
andere ebene
und das fand ich spannend eben mich da
rein zu begeben
die möglichkeit ein nicht umarmen zu
können ist schon komisch zu sagen wer
den rechtlichen rahmen können schon ein
komisches gefühl widerstrebt so ein
bisschen menschlichen bedürfnis hatte
ich jetzt das ist natürlich nicht im
klassischen sinne kontrovers das ist
keine politische debatte aber es bringt
einen natürlich gerade in dieser
isolations sicht die wir derzeit auch
teilweise haben weil wir uns einfach
nicht persönlich getroffen haben oder
treffen können bringt ja verbindet
einmal ein stück weit
und wenn man so etwas macht dann sollte
dass ich alle gelten und nicht irgendwie
eine zweiklassengesellschaft dadurch
entstehen weil das hat halt immer gesagt
man hat ein geschmäckle
was ist aber wenn wir
das ganze weiter ziehen die risikogruppe
ist ist die jetzt ein bisschen hart der
welche sage die in den ganzen prozess in
den wirtschaftlichen prozess und so
weiter hat die geringere rolle spielen
damit jemand einen fremden in kontakt zu
kommen den man vorher nicht kannte was
man ansonsten vielleicht mal in der bahn
oder einer längeren zugfahrt erlebt dass
man mit jemandem ins gespräch kommt aber
es geht ja gerade meistens nicht also
nimmt man so eine gelegenheit wie
deutschland spricht und das ist ein weg
der vielleicht nicht so intendiert war
aber der auch völlig in ordnung
warum machen die menschen mit
deutschland spricht einige von ihnen
sind wiederholungstäter die sind schon
ins dritte oder vierte mal dabei
das interesse an einer anderen meinung
aus einer blase herauskommen ist eine
wichtige motivation
wie ist das eben themen zu diskutieren
den mann überhaupt nicht kennt über
entfernung um andere sichtweisen kennen
sondern oder auch andere meinung
eine andere ist auch die lust auf ein
sehr kontroverses gespräch am anfang
denken viele auch das ist ja gar nicht
so am ende gehen sie aus dem gespräch
und haben eine andere perspektive kennen
gelernt oder ein jahr was vor einem jahr
bei ihnen war wird zu einem nein weil es
gute argumente in dem gespräch gab die
sie überzeugt haben
themen die immer wieder diskutiert
worden sind gerade auch auf die monate
die noch kommen werden mit kommunen ja
schon fast eine sehnsucht dass die
regierung klare exit strategien eine
lockerung strategien diskutiert und
kommuniziert das was mir fehlt ist zum
beispiel ist sogar auch unterschiedliche
meinung bei der masken pflicht
ich habe mir mal erklären lassen oder
mein arbeitgeber hat das natürlich auch
gemacht wie man das richtig macht
wenn ich dann in der straße in den
straßen oder in der stadt gucken was da
los ist
das ist nicht umsetzbar
und natürlich der datenschutz wurde
diskutiert mit blick auf die geplante
tracing app die infektionsketten nach
erfolgen soll
da gab es also zwei argumentation
strenge ist eine wahl entsprechend das
sind meine daten die wir nicht
preisgeben und das andere war dieses
abdecken
ich mache es mache mir zu weit geht um
menschenleben
falls sie unsere aktion verpasst haben
oder gerne noch mal das ein oder andere
gespräch nachlesen möchte
gehen sie einfach unsere seite rezept
net dort gibt es die übersichtsseite
dort werden sämtliche artikel videos und
grafiken kapital
[Musik]